[Music]
whether we're talking about the early
days of justin tv
or twitch's current continuing surge in
popularity
online streaming has always been about
entertainment
we did this this is us baby i get the
money we did this though
we hit these milestones i'm gonna spend
it on a ferrari but
we get to enjoy me enjoying the ferrari
and as streaming has grown we've seen it
become part of the mainstream
with some of the biggest names in
popular culture joining the party
yo chad who should i kill next
oh hey i'm not
after years of struggling to gain
acceptance streaming is
now just a regular everyday pastime and
not just that
it's become a more respected and viable
career path
the success stories we see today aren't
just following the trails of early
adopters or
esports retirees they're following
people intentionally trying to reach the
top
and some of them are using their
knowledge of entertainment
to do it in today's video we got
ourselves
[Music]
that's zach lane better known as
zeelaner he's one of the biggest names
in cod
warzone and if you're into his stream
it's pretty easy to see why
in uh in the sky uh straight ahead i'm
about to beam him real quick he's right
here
live mark the
he's target he's gone forever
i just my pants
[Applause]
[Applause]
ah holy
oh my god you're popping but zealander
didn't just stumble his way into the
spotlight
no his rise was the product of craft
diligence and an
endless supply of charisma traits that
made him
just what the doctor ordered champions
club
brand new person we've never played with
and i got a feeling ladies and gentlemen
i got a feeling but of course being one
of warzone's biggest content creators
comes with more than just praise and
adoration and the attention that
zealander's disgusting highlights have
brought him
have also made him a target off the
server i hit the same shots
i make the same decisions no matter what
and
it's because i play this game a lot okay
so
how did this vocal virtuoso from the
east coast become facebook gaming's call
of duty king
who you've seen dropping to 46 mom on
facebook huh
who you seeing dropping your 46 mom on
facebook
how exactly did he end up forming
streaming's hottest new tandem
with the disrespectful one and is there
anything actually suspicious about him
dunking on people using a controller
[Applause]
did he come from
okay so if you're unfamiliar with the
doc's hard carrying charismatic protege
here's a little background before he was
popping domes in verdansk and prior to
becoming one of the
fastest rising stars on smoke master
zuck's big blue platform
zach lane had long been an aspiring
musician
from the age of 13 he'd played gigs at
coffee shops and festivals
but by the end of high school he
announced his talent to the world on a
canadian reality tv series
called the launch
[Music]
but when he wasn't making his guitar
gently weep or working part-time at best
buy
zach could be found spending his free
time enjoying
another of his lifelong passions playing
video games
and as he told the becoming a streamer
podcast after seeing the explosion of
streaming with fortnite in 2017
he decided to give it a shot under the
name z
laner i started on twitch to answer your
full question
streaming like for seven or eight months
um on twitch with no real
big you know followage or anything i had
this one time where i killed myth in a
fortnite
duo match or something and i had this
big surge of viewers one time and
i thought i was like getting hosted but
it was just literally just for killing
him
and i was live i'd like twitch in my
name or something and that was my
closest
like ever to any type of good viewership
on twitch now getting the better of a
massive streamer like myth
may have been a cool feather for z laner
to add to his cap
but it didn't result in any long-term
gain for his stream
it was only after he made a victim out
of facebook gaming's dimes
that everything changed for z this guy
is the reason why
i switched to facebook this guy i that
that
allowed me to quit my part-time job and
and uh
and and my and my gigging on the
weekends to you know pay for the small
amount of bills that i had as a 18 year
old 19 year old
he shared his his fan base with me he
showed me some love he believed in me
and he uh he's the reason why
why uh a lot of this is is where it is
now so man i can't thank times enough
after being recruited by dimes to stream
exclusively for facebook gaming
people began to take real notice of z
laner he had this
unlikely blend of skill
let's go bro attitude
that was doc that was pretty toxic i i
will admit it and star
[Music]
power
[Music]
now as his audience on facebook
continued to grow zee laner
like many other battle royale streamers
eventually made the swap to call of duty
war zone
but that wasn't the change that took
people by surprise
no what absolutely rocked them to their
core
was the fact that he opted to play with
the controller
instead of a mouse and keyboard they
always ask and they want to see the
angle they want to see what i do because
a lot of people don't know for
i mean for those of you that don't know
i play claw uh claw basically is just a
different way
to hold your controller instead of
holding it with your index fingers on
the triggers
you just take your right index finger
where the buttons are on this side
and you put that over the buttons and
then you take your middle finger and you
put it here that's a way to play claw
but it didn't matter what hardware z had
opted to use
the guy was a monster and his skill for
the game
combined with his positive vibes and
unbridled confidence
was turning him into a streaming
sensation
it's not you gotta wait for me to get
full health
oh my lord
[Applause]
that was close [ __ ] one
no these guys there's no way there's no
way
you survive there's just no way they
both ran right past me dude
[Music]
this is like this is why i have so many
oh these guys are the biggest i i hate
to say it but they're
they're they're kind of bots as z
laner's channel grew bigger and as
highlight reels became more expansive
the waves he was making began to spread
across the platform
and in august of 2020 when someone in
the z fame donated to doctor disrespect
suggesting that the two joined
forces for an upcoming tournament z
caught wind of it
and seized the opportunity i literally
heard that clip and like 15 minutes
later like it was live
and then 50 minutes later i i like
messaged my editor i was like listen
throw a few of these clips that i sent
the other day together
uh that 40 bomb that 52 kill game all
this type of stuff get it in the clip
show the endings of the game show the
energy all that stuff because i know
that's what he wants to see
and i just said put that together and
i'm going to put that on twitter i'm
going to tag a minute i'm going to say
if you need a tournament you know a
teammate i heard you need a teammate
and you know whatever and he ended up
messaging and commenting on it no
joke like 10 or 15 minutes after i
tweeted i was freaking out
i got a message from dr disrespect
i got a mag of the dm i got a dm bro he
said yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah he said let's get
some games in on wednesday yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and it
didn't take long for the two of them to
hit things off
i'm almost done i'm almost done take
your time
that makes no sense this guy's broken
broken more up top more up top
yep
i got uh that sound i'm pushing up yeah
go ahead i'm gonna i'm gonna play i'm
gonna play
you're better you're just always better
way better better looking too
i hear more inside mike and it might
keep the window here on the left
you're better doc you're better man
i'm finishing your guys i'm dead oh
three steps about the 360.
okay hold on doc hold on hold on
yeah yeah hold on i'm gonna let him get
up
give me just a little bit of hope you
know it's a little bit eliminated
yo baby let's go chat
with you gonna play with you man
you shredded me bro you
[Music]
there were a few things about the
partnership between z and doc that
just made sense firstly doc's mysterious
twitch ban had not only left him unable
to stream on that platform
but it also prevented him from appearing
in other twitch streamers broadcasts
and because z had spent the better part
of two years building his audience on
facebook there were no collaborative
hurdles on top of that
zee brought a positive and determined
energy to the stream which made him a
natural sounding board
for the doc's commentary the two guys
just pumped each other up and were
clearly having fun
a wise man once said you know mm-hmm
[Music]
my
[Music]
i'm telling you i don't use auto-tune
lastly z-laner's reputation as an
incredible player was completely
justified
he was fully capable of dropping huge
kill tallies in his games with doc
but most importantly whatever they
did it was just always entertaining
i don't have the angle it's knocked one
stop two
beautiful beautiful i'll push it with
you now i'm getting a truck
stock three night getting shot from the
other guy
another one stealth right here on the
wall knocked more they're knocked
another
good night they all self
knocked another oh my god knocked
another
they're all selfing they're all like
selfing
behind me self oh
hey jeff funzie uh you know i had a
little fun he called me a [ __ ] after
i i think he's angry in time the duo
became known
as dripping in heat because
honestly why wouldn't they be the sniper
you could say was it was dripping you
know what i mean it was dripping
it was it was looking good it was
dripping in a bit of heat you know
for all that aim assist that you get i
mean you use okay
okay the new partnership that z and doc
had formed was mutually beneficial
now doc obviously brought a ton of new
eyes to z later but
z also seemed to really bring out the
best in dock
oh i'm dead
i just
looking just thrown right in here oh my
god
oh doc doc oh cliff ladies and gentlemen
one more on the map and just like that
game time
what a performance man what are they
giving you a skin in this game that's
what i'm
that's what listen when you're dropping
50 kill
games in warzone uh when are they giving
you a skin in this game z
and of course once you're playing with
the two time things start to move
quickly
we're gonna have to get some games in
with z
later on today if he but he doesn't play
on mondays
i just thought of that now
thanks to z's exploits with the dock he
soon found himself sharing the spotlight
with some of
the biggest streamers on twitch you've
been playing with dakala right
yeah man i've been taking that role ever
since she's been
no man it's been a vibe that's cool man
yeah it's nice to meet you i hear you're
insane so i expect a full carry
i mean if you can carry a knock you can
definitely carry me and he's even
rubbing elbows with
massive personalities outside of the
gaming world we're gonna be playing with
ufc
featherweight champion of the world max
holloway
are the best players pc guys with the
mouse there's some guys that there's
there's some guys that play pc and some
guys that play controller that's just
like neck and neck so jamie what do you
think that's right i mean the guy he's
talking about earlier nick merks who
plays with the controller
yeah yeah good luck so yeah z laner bro
right
try to switch up this guy is he the best
guy he's really good
they're really oh my god wait listen joe
hey
joe if you ever want to talk about
streaming and gaming
and then maybe afterwards you know do
some dmtm hop into a sleep deprivation
tank together
i'm your man i'm there but since he
teamed up with doc
it hasn't all been smooth sailing and
shout outs on the joe rogan experience
with tons of eyes watching his every
move
came other challenges including
accusations
of cheating and these were accusations
that zealander was not going to take
lightly i'm gonna be addressing the
accusations
and uh that have been going around
lately of uh z laner
using aimbot wallhacks whatever it may
be after showing his task manager in a
single long take
zee played an entire round with his
controller and
monitor on separate cameras debunking
the baseless accusations
that had been thrown his way and of
course the dock had his back
the entire time let him know z just
don't don't don't knock it just cause
you
just think you're just because you're
insecure about your own abilities and
you you see someone being able to pull
some [ __ ] off that you can't do yourself
zee's level-headed response was well
received and
even though these kinds of accusations
never fully disappear
zee and his community have largely moved
on and while z
regularly combines forces with doc and
their unlikely partnership has continued
to produce
classic moments he doesn't live in the
shadow of his friend and mentor
with now over 650 thousand followers on
facebook
zealander finds himself as one of the
biggest streamers on the platform
and it's a stage that he's more than
prepared to shine on
with or without a guitar in hand because
the z
fam knows that every time their boy goes
live
it's gonna be a bang
[Music]
and honestly for a kid from moncton new
brunswick who set out to break his way
into the streaming world
his continued success is just the latest
twist
in a long road to the top
the success stories we see today jesus
that was the voice cry
my god today oh [ __ ]
knock the mic but zelenor didn't stumble
his
christ but i'm gonna keep hitting my
microphone
because now it's here and it's driving
crazy honestly man all these zoomers out
here talking about there being something
wrong
and for dance but only the real ones
know
that it was a bloody convention out
there